so today we have two really fascinating
guests I'm so so so excited about this
interview I met these guys before and I
promise you this is going to blow your
socks off
we have they're both but well thanks
guys except for this guy who's done does
he already knew he was prepared okay no
socks so they are the founders the
cofounders of the company Zook how many
of you ever heard of zooks before great
okay they are making I'm going to read
this fully developing fully autonomous
vehicles and the supporting ecosystem
required to bring the technology market
now Jim Kelly clay came from Australia
and he has run several media companies
then internationally
international firms and we have
Jeffersons Jessie Levinson who's a
co-founder and CTO who are just a degree
in computer science here at PhD and also
postdoc where he worked on autonomous
vehicles so please join me in welcoming
our special gas leave our CTO and our
CEO of this company can you give us a
little story of how you got here maybe
each and you can give us a little bit of
time to tell your stories how you ended
up here sitting here on this stage sure
you know I think for me my journey in
robotics started around 2012 when it's
like watching from Melbourne Australia
from one of my animations to do is what
Google is doing with their self-driving
car program sitting here today looking
back they kind of I think lied to us
they made it look a little bit easier
than what it actually is but for me at
the time had the the insight that AI and
mobility rate autonomy and mobility is
about much more than just incremental
adaptation to the automobile it's more
than a order pilot feature for a freeway
this technology is going to reboot
mobility as we know it you know the
previous mobility age before the
automobile was course a horse and
carriage and we're actually in that age
around 6,000 years it's around 4000 BC
we domesticated the horse put the axle
on the wheel and got coachbuilding so
what let us switch from from one
mobility age to the next arguably it was
invention of the internal combustion
engine
where we got to a technology level on
this planet where we could mechanize the
horses biomechanical power what was the
right exploitation that invention well
it wasn't to put it in the coach and
keep the horse people try that but it
didn't work particularly well the right
the right exploitation was to get rid of
the horse change the architecture of the
coach quite radically to get through to
something like the Model T Ford right
and so the people that that one weren't
the coach builders it was people
understood mechanical engineering and
then importantly how to industrialize it
and the insight we have at Zeus is that
a on my a eye mobility will take us from
the age of the automobile into the next
mobility age and we think that's
robotics because what we're really doing
is bringing a narrow AI sort of a horse
level intelligence if you like we
created horsepower now gain horse level
intelligence to to the vehicle and
taking the human out of the loop and if
that's true
Zeus was founded to ask the question
well what would the full realization of
AI mobility be can we imagine that and
if we can we build it not in ten years
but today great so every one of us at
Duke like to say works ten years in the
future and that's the journey we're on
is is to be focused on what is the for
realization of this technology and let's
see we can make that today I love this
idea of bringing the horse intelligence
to the car I get my car differently so
Jessie you've been thinking about this a
long time what brought to you at this
stage yeah so I I got to spend a bunch
of time at Stanford I actually
specifically came to Stanford in large
part because Stanford started working on
self-driving cars and it seemed to me
that of all the applications of computer
science and AI a self-driving cars had
by far the most potential to impact
Society in a whole variety of positive
ways economically environmentally and
socially so it also was you know kind of
cool and seemed like it'd be fun to work
on so I started working on it with
sebastian run just in time to start
working on the DARPA urban challenge
which was in 2007 and it was the first
time that we'd sort of gotten some level
of actual interaction between autonomous
vehicles and other dynamic objects in
the world which was really exciting I
got to work on a really small team and
be part of that and I kind of stayed in
academia for a bit instead of going to
Google or one of the car companies
because although I really a little bit
of temp some photography but I really
wanted to turn into a product but I
wasn't I wasn't really convinced that
the car company sort of saw the future
like how was this technology really
going to actually make it to the market
and Google is doing super cool stuff I
have a lot of friends there and they
were know doing amazing technology but
also just didn't seem like they quite
knew what you know what was the product
going to be right I didn't know either
so I was sort of like well I'll just
keep you know working on this this
research and I met Tim about three years
ago and he sort of came up with this
idea for you know how would you actually
come up with a whole new platform a new
business model way more ambitious than
than anything I'd heard anybody else
talking about and so my first reaction
was well this is probably nuts right
because it's you know so different and
and I spent an hour with him and
actually sounds pretty amazing and it
seemed like it probably was you know the
future of Transportation and cities so
we spent a few much getting to know each
other and I got really excited because I
felt like I could take their work that
you know sort of my team and I had been
doing in Stanford and then actually
start to apply it to what what I thought
would would in fact be the full
realization of that technology so we got
started yeah but no almost three years
ago now so okay paint a picture of what
the future of autonomous vehicles are so
okay think about five years from now
then hopefully you'll be launched by
then ten years maybe even 20 years what
what's the vision that you guys have for
the future not thrown out of money by
then we have your investors in the ruins
edifice we hear them laughing oh not to
be making too much money by thanks we
want to keep the blue sky but hopefully
customer adoption I mean I think you
know I mean Jesse and I you know we
really started Suk's
because we thought it was the best
application of our time and talents you
know we didn't do this because we want
to flip the business we do it because we
want to found the future and so I think
for me you know what we're working
towards Duke's run a five-year vehicle
development program kicked off in 2015
my seg kicked off I mean kicked off like
two guys one laptop and we are aiming to
conclude that in 2020 and be ready to
scale a fully autonomous mobility
service and see
and so I think we're both working for is
you know been up at the Ferry Building
hopefully in San Francisco eating at a
burger joint and watching one of our
ground up robots going down Embarcadero
picking up a customer and taken to the
where they want to be you know I think
that's the reward that we're looking for
is to create that magical moment so
Jesse is this true this is like you're
looking at essentially mobile robots
that are going to pick me up anywhere I
want and take the where I want to go
that's the idea I mean they're very
actually quite intelligent they have a
lot of you know a lot of computing power
a lot of sensors and I actually hope
that they'll be a little smarter than
horses somewhere in between horses and
pee okay
great maybe they'll be even smarter than
some people well be great or maybe some
drivers though they're only be a lot
more attentive so what are the
trade-offs that you're considering right
now that you're developing this
technology right the hope is to launch
when when when are we going to see these
on the road I will we've already
launched on our private test track
actually in 2015 the first seven months
actually created an on-demand
point-to-point electric autonomous
mobility service so that a lot to say
isn't it that from an app on my phone
you can push a button and the robot will
come on that facility find you and take
you where you want to go and then we
have a very detailed roadmap from now
until 2020 where we were all that thing
you know Jesse we already have you know
Toyota Highlanders that we've hacked
into and taken parasitic control of the
ECU and put our own computing centers on
we have our license from the state of
California so they're out testing in the
field in Menlo Park actually and you
know by 2020 we want to we want to
create the full the full thing so I want
to paint a picture I have a chance to
chat with you at another time and so I
have this image in my mind of these
vehicles that you're creating and I
understand that they're not like
anything that we currently see on the
road right because if no one's ever ever
going to drive them they don't need a
steering wheel they don't need a
dashboard
they don't need Windows they don't need
mirrors how do you design a product like
that from the ground up when you really
are not comparing it to something that
already exists well I mean that's that's
half the fun right is is if you have a
legacy product and you
steering wheel in there and you're
trying to retrofit what I call roof
racks you know a lot of developers out
there just putting sensors into a
Baqarah architecture you know I think
you're taking a complex product and
making it more complex and then that
structure of that vehicle is designed to
human vision so if you take that
constraint out and say well the
passenger never has to take physical
control of this vehicle will that's on
us right it actually gives you more
degrees of freedom to optimize for
machine vision rather than a hybrid
architecture while actually removing
complexity from the vehicle you know by
getting in the steering wheel the
instrument panel side mirrors windscreen
wipers you know it you know we actually
get rid of a lot of a lot of hardware
out of the vehicle which is really
important for a startup to reduce the
build materials and Alpha's get to
market faster super interesting so can
you paint a picture of what this user
experience will be when this thing comes
up and picks me up at the Ferry Building
no okay Joe now this is really important
because you actually are in stealth mode
right I'm going to guess it's not
because you don't know it's because you
just don't want to tell us yes and why
is it that you're in stealth mode you
know a lot of companies choose that
decision for very important strategic
reasons and I think it's important to
understand why are you choosing not to
tell us what this experience is going to
be like yeah I mean that's a really good
question
you know sometimes it's a bit of media
saying this like super secretive startup
called tux right and it's not that we're
secretive at all like but in the company
we're very transparent with everyone
about what we're doing we don't
compartmentalize too much because we
want everyone to understand what we're
doing this is very holistic you know you
have to be able to see how everything
work to solve this so me it's really
just a question of focus I mean we've
been on a lot a lot like we've got a lot
of work to do and so for me by being
stealth mode we can just focus on
perfecting the fundamental art and
science of what it means to create this
technology without the distraction of
you know going to too many you know the
first one we've learn actually going to
many conferences or having to have a
rinky-dink website or anything like that
you know to me that stuff's just a
distraction we really want to focus as a
company on what we're doing and we also
have a point of view on what we're doing
you know and so we are part of it is we
don't want to
say with a megaphone to our competitors
this is how we think this can work
because that's part of our competitive
advantage it might be so crazy that they
wouldn't do it anyway
what's the basis for doing party right a
your competitors aren't seeing it but
also your potential customers aren't
seeing it and able to give feedback
right so how do you get feedback and how
do you set up the ability to pivot right
to make some changes if you're going the
wrong direction if if you're not
actually out there sharing what you're
doing with the world yeah so I mean
within the company we do it we do do
user testing you know we make like
interior models of the we make models of
the interior and we bring in people and
we have our UX researchers that come in
and take notes without me there so I
can't influences right all this kind of
stuff so so we go through we go through
that diligence but you know there's also
some pretty good heuristics as well like
I think you know it's over in in Europe
we've actually built a one-to-one
version of the vehicle with the
industrial design and you know
unsolicited when people stand around and
look at it you can tell from their
reaction that we we have something here
whereas it's very clear when when people
don't like something because I just
might as interested or they feel awkward
about it so we're we're super excited
about what building it's really fun it's
really different the industrial design
by the way is not what's you know on the
internet from what I and a couple of
years ago the DNA is the same in terms
of the architecture we're building but
we're actually creating what we call a
microbus a suit which is a compact four
cedar to further mobility so Jesse as
the CTO and with all of the technical
knowledge how much are you actually
having to build yourself versus buying
off-the-shelf is this something that ok
all the technology actually already
exists and it's just piecing it together
an interesting way are you actually yeah
reinventing the wheel well haha or
inventing video well it does have wheels
but they're not steering wheels it yeah
it's it's a it's a mixture but I think
you know one of the things that makes it
challenging is that nobody has solved
this type of problem before right
there's a there's a big gap between
autonomous sort of features that you can
get on the car today and then true level
5 mobility which means you get in a
vehicle and it takes you where you want
to go and you really
have to do anything and in fact you
can't even do anything other than say
where you want to go or hey I want to go
to the vehicle you know from a from a
star tech startups perspective one of
the really exciting things is that we
get to do the hardware and the software
and the service jointly and holistically
and I think people some vendors don't
appreciate how big of an advantage that
is if you look at you know what Apple
did with the iPhone
they didn't just write a new operating
system and put it on a Motorola RAZR or
a blackberry and they also didn't make a
new hardware device that was running
Windows Mobile phone from 2006 they
could have done either of those things
but I don't think it would have made
nearly the impact on the market that
they were able to achieve with the
iPhone now I think with autonomous
vehicles especially fully autonomous
vehicles I think that integration
between hardware and software and the
user experience is even more important
than it was with with cell phones right
and so one of the fun things that we get
to do but also the very difficult things
is we get to think holistically about
you know where do we put sensors what
type of sensors do we need how much
computing power do we need you know it's
probably more sensors and more computers
than you're going to be able to buy on a
car in the next couple years because our
business model is very different we
don't actually sell these vehicles to
customers we own and operate this fleet
and then you can use them the way you
use uber and lyft to just hopefully be
much better and you know even cheaper to
operate because you're not paying the
driver so we do need to develop our own
software our own AI our own algorithms
we're not using you know mobile I or
anybody else's AI technology it's
completely developed in-house at Zuke's
when it comes to computers and sensors
you know we we as much as possible buy
things off the shelf or work with
technology partners to you know get
access to their their upcoming products
and then when it comes to the sort of
physical mechatronic layer of the
vehicle it's also really powerful that
that we get to design a level of
robustness and some amount of fail
operational into that design that cars
today are not built for cars today are
not built to drive a hundred thousand
miles a year for four years and they're
also not designed to be necessarily safe
when a whole bunch of components might
fail the good news is we don't have to
reinvent for example you know the entire
concept of an electric car the way Tesla
had to do you know what Tesla did ten
years ago from a vehicle engineering
perspective it was quite amazing we
very very difficult and you know there
was really no supply chain for Eevee
technology that in the last decade Tesla
and now a bunch of other companies make
electric cars in quite some scale so if
we're looking for batteries you know and
motors and steering columns and sort of
things you know sometimes we might need
to innovate a little bit with the
supplier but for the most part it's
about building a new architecture but
not reinventing every single hardware
component in the vehicle so what do you
guys see as the biggest risks are they
technical this market risks are the
regulation risks and this is a really
complicated product and experience and
environment what is what are the things
that keep you up at night I don't mean
to be cute but I think the biggest risk
is actually unknown unknowns in the
abstract
right because they're the things you
don't see that really hurt you looking
back right and so one thing I've been
learning you know sort of leading with
Jessie zooks is it's really important
the game almost in a way when you're
starting your businesses is to bring
into the company as fast as you can the
main experts to expand those unknown
unknowns right that's that's really
important work though only to go faster
it'll stop you from from some scrim
colliding something you didn't see
coming
so I think you know for me that's really
important is the culture of the company
who do we have around it you know not
just the board level that advises we
have tremendous advisors around Zook we
have people like Carl basses was
recently the CEO of Autodesk you know we
have Gonzalo Rey who's the CTO of move
we have Andrew Howard who's a senior
software engineer down at SpaceX like
people that have shipped a lot of
product in very advanced systems that
are giving really good advice to you
know what is a young team at Zook
something we have over 60 doctors PhDs
postdocs from around the world working
on the computer science aspects of what
we're doing at Zuke's
and so I think that's really important
in the abstract is to get rid of the the
unknown unknowns as fast as you can and
part of that has also been pragmatic you
know Roland having a lot of conversation
you know based on first principles or
that's that's that's rational and
academic it's like well let's just put
something on the vehicle garden tester
and get some data and let the data speak
to to what's important India risk for
business so even though you're not
telling us what you did you certainly
have told investors
they have given you a lot of money you
have been you have been able to raise a
tremendous amount up to the vision that
you've sold how did you inspire people
to get behind this very radical idea
that really essentially you know jumped
over a lot of things that people are now
developing yeah I mean it was pretty
crazy raising our series a you know
Jesse and I really had to go out to the
market and ask for you know unusually
large amount of money because the
complexity of what we're doing you know
we're creating a full-stack
next-generation
autonomous mobility experience it's
vertically integrated is not cheap you
know all our competitors we you know
their budgets are 1 billion plus on in
this marketplace and yet where we're
entering a market that is a 10 trillion
dollar market right and it is about to
disrupt and will it be incumbents will
be a new entrant and so for the
investment community they get the size
of the opportunity and Zuk Zuk is in a
very unique position because as far as
we know we're the only startup and even
compared to some tech giants and OEM
giants they're actually trying to do the
whole thing under one roof
right and so we're a big bed but the
outcome you know can also be a big
reward as well and so to find a group of
investors that more or less five years
out from a product a customer with a lot
of technical risk or a regulatory risk
right who had put in you know 250
million dollars into our series a which
is you know once two orders of magnitude
above what is normal and for less than
20% of the business as well you know
that's a very special set of investors
and we we were able to find them we're
able to have the right set of
conversations with them and you know I'm
sure Jesse would agree like we have just
brilliant investors around this company
you know DFG of course have been early
stage seed investors through to a round
and help leave that companies like $0.10
lux Capital blackbird really high
caliber venture capitalists that are not
looking for a quick exit they're looking
to work with founders that want to
create something big and so we
able to find those people and it's
really the moonshot I mean it's if it
works is to be amazing and it's
remarkable now who do you see as your
biggest competitors is it folks who are
already working on autonomous vehicles
like Google or is it folks who are doing
something totally radical but you might
not even know about it's an interesting
question I mean it's actually a little
hard to say at this point right because
nobody nobody has level-5 technology on
the market do us a favor and describe
what that is with level 5 is yeah
absolutely so so the SAE came up with
this series of autonomy sort of rankings
levels level one is like you know cruise
control basic stuff level two is you can
do sort of adaptive cruise control and
lane-keeping it's just sort of like the
Tesla autopilot system that you can get
today level three means sort of a fully
autonomous vehicle but you still have to
be sitting behind the steering wheel
paying attention because at any point in
time you might decide it doesn't really
know what it's doing and you have to
take over but other than that it can you
know get through intersections do
traffic lights and sort of do almost
everything level four means that the car
is fully autonomous you don't even have
to pay attention but it's only able to
operate in a certain domain so maybe
it's you know fully autonomous but only
during the day time we're fully
autonomous but only you know in this
particular chunk of the city right and
then level five means it's sort of flow
autonomous and it can drive anywhere and
pretty much anything a human can drive
it could drive so of course that is the
goal that's what we're trying to get to
at zoos so I'm curious so it's really
different if all the cars on the road
are autonomous and they all have the
same rules and the same etiquette but
when you have a car an autonomous
vehicle on the road that is not being
controlled it all by a person and you
also have human controlled cars there's
going to be some mismatch I heard the
other day about the concept of bullying
alternative vehicles right the people
who know that well they know that Thomas
car is going to be very polite so you
can cut it off don't try that okay yeah
I mean you know this really speaks to
what we call social robotics and it's
loose we talked about the car becoming a
character right and this is why we think
a car it was autonomous wouldn't
actually
work in the marketplace because it
actually doesn't have the lighting and
sound actuation that we think you need
to deal with social scenarios like that
you know we have a personality
personality for our vehicle we call it
friendly but fierce so it would be nice
but it can also dial up certain certain
attributes if you're being a pest and
then our vehicle you know it has it has
some super cool features so you know if
you're driving through the Tenderloin 2
a.m. and someone comes out in front of
the vehicle and is messing with it well
you know most autonomous vehicles will
just be stuck either with no one in it
and so the customers waiting or
someone's in it and they're freaking out
well our vehicle has special features
it's actually symmetrical it's what we
call bi-directional with the electric
motors it can drive either way equally
well and we use active LED illumination
to define dynamically what the front or
the rear is and so we have this neat
little maneuver where if someone was
standing in front of the vehicle messing
with us
we could actually flip our lights and
flop over the other side of the road and
drive away I call it the French maneuver
does the car also signal whether it's
being friendly or fierce suddenly does
it change color does it send out signals
does it do something to say hey I'm
going from my friendly much of my fears
mode all of that all of that okay so
really does our personality okay I'm not
going to ask some rude questions about
what it does okay when it gets mad so
what is the business model here I mean
you you allude to the fact that this
will be a fleet that will be either is
this ugly that you'll control you said
it would be like over would ever buy
these and use them is this something or
something that you're going to be
managing centrally well I mean companies
like uber traditionally don't like capex
on their balance sheet so that's
something for them to answer but I think
yeah there's two ways to look at this
one through technology and one is
through social you know I think on a
social level there's clear trend lines
in megacities that young people or
people who live in cities don't want to
own a car it's a pain I don't have to
park it on have to do an insurance and
what I really want is on-demand mobility
where I push a button it picks me up and
takes me want to be and that's it
and that's really the mission statement
of our company is connecting people in
places right we love connection and we
want to and we want to have a
physicality to how that is and so I
think people people don't want to own
the vehicle they just want to pay for it
use and we actually like that as a
company because what's happening is with
these these advanced AI systems they
require continuous improvement by large
team of software engineers and a lot of
computation happening in the cloud and a
lot of data coming off them and that
costs money and so if you have the
automotive model which is you know if
you're a t1 like Bosch and you work on a
rack and pinion steering system and you
might spend four years writing some
carefully coded firmware that goes on
that system and you sell it once to OEM
who then sells it to to a customer once
and they monetize once I mean if you
need to continuously update that
software you've got no way to pay for it
whereas these vehicles will have
over-the-air updates going out to them
you know quite a high frequency and so
you actually need the subscription model
of getting paid per mile to actually
fund the updating of your robots because
they they have they have almost like
living code on them and so it's good in
that people don't want to own cars or
live in cities they want on-demand and
paper use and it's great for us because
that helps us make the product better
just keep evolving and it's and it's
also a much better use of materials
right because we all know well you don't
know but people who work in the industry
know that you know cars are actually
driven 4 percent of the day on average
so 96 percent of time all the resources
put in a product sit idle and so I love
the idea that if you're not using this
product someone else is right and so
again this is where you do ground up
because you need to solve a product
that's going to drive 16 hours of the
day 365 days of the year it's just we
mentioned it's one hundred thousand
hundred thirty thousand miles and so if
you're thinking to get that just by
retrofitting a car good luck to you
right you need to you need to create a
purpose-built
architecture and product experience to
solve for them and you know to add to
that you know this technology changes
very quickly right I mean people are
used to buying a car and owning it for
10 years or so right the technology that
people are putting into autonomous
driving today you know in 10 years is
going to be pretty obsolete right if you
look at the cell phone you had 10 years
ago it certainly wasn't an iPhone
because it actually didn't have iPhones
10 years ago although all and be able to
say that for another months but you know
it's kind of crazy this the idea being
you buy a car and you buy a $50,000 car
you know a Tesla 80 hundred thousand
dollar car right and you know has
several thousand dollars of computers
and sensors in it it's super cool right
it's by far the best system on them are
but you know in five years ten years
like it's not signing me very useful
anymore and one of the things that we're
excited about is that if we own and
operate our fleets we can continuously
upgrade the technology as it you know as
it changes every year or two which would
be very frustrating if you bought a car
and then a couple years later you like
up not so much is this dependent upon
any changes in the ambient
infrastructure that changes in the roads
or changes in communication networks
that you're dependent upon yes when Zeus
launches we need to ban all cars from
hahahaha America it makes our job a lot
easier because the problem is not really
us it's people hitting us right and so
so that you know Jessa can speak too so
the technology is is designed to work in
a mixed mode environment in cities and
we're not really looking to the local
mayor to roll out the bank check to
change the infrastructure of the city
that would be prohibitive and so so you
know if if your goal was to create a
self-driving vehicle for like a car park
you know Disneyland or a campus you
could really lightweight the vehicle and
in fact we built that in 2015 our our
ambition is to create you know a
ground-up vehicle that will have
five-star crash safety who will have
airbags in it it will go from a surface
street to a freeway and I'll deal with
harsh weather this is a full-stack
hardware product that if we get riding
can scale on the market pace place very
quickly interesting in a few minutes I'm
going to open up for questions from the
audience so start thinking about the
hardest questions you have for these
guys well is that one one extra thought
to that you know it sometimes people say
wouldn't your problem be so much easier
if you had vehicle to vehicle
communication or vehicle to
infrastructure and you know what if
cities were willing to spend hundreds
and millions of dollars and had all
these fancy features and the reality is
well first of all that's just not
happening in the next few years no
matter what even if I wanted it and then
second of all it wouldn't make our lives
as much easier as you might think
because even if every other car on the
road had v2v technology and even if
cities at all this fancy infrastructure
your vehicle still needs to see
bicyclists and pedestrians and all these
other dynamic entities in the world that
definitely aren't going to have this
type of technology on them so no matter
what you have to build a perception
system that can see the world around you
and make sense of it so you need the
sensing and the
the AI and the understanding and if you
sort of need to understand that anyway
then you know understanding cars is just
sort of one extra thing you need to
understand now we know that with all
technology there's a dark side right if
we think about cars in general it led to
urban sprawl and air pollution are you
thinking about the dark side the
downside the consequences of this
technology and how are you or are you
doing anything to try to mitigate that
so what are things you're concerned
about it how are you thinking about that
yeah I mean I'm I'm personally pretty
optimistic about the technology you know
those who wouldn't be doing it you know
it is true that the car was seen as
clean and solving the problem of a lot
of horse pollution one it was happening
in town because there's so many horses
you know but you know this is one of the
reasons you know some of our competitors
for example how else fielding vehicles
that have internal combustion engines I
mean we're pure Eevee because it's for
us you know in our most dense urban
areas you know in the United Nations
predicted in 2050 75 percent of the
world's population they're going to live
in dense urban areas and so we want that
to be safe we want it to be clean we
want people to at a jog and not be
getting tailpipe emissions right and we
want it to be access to the whole
community low cost and we wanted to be a
wonderful product experience you know
which is something we're also very
passionate about it suits as well and so
I think I think for us there's a lot of
positives I think some of the negatives
are as we said there's always
engineering to life right and so when
you have a new technology is going to
displace some other incumbent industries
and in in Silicon Valley I've been
living here for two and a half years
it's called disruptive technologies
right but I kind of react against that
that term because I'm like I'm not
really creating disruptive company I'm
creating a constructive company you know
for a new business to get up in the
marketplace I think has to be an order
of magnitude at least better and ahead
of the competition right and so you're
actually making things better but
there's also loss in that and so you
might have some unemployment from
professional drivers like taxis and this
sort of thing but you need to look at
the the entire system of a city for
example you know if you are able to make
that fifty city drive more efficiently
it may be more safe and a better and a
better service for a city of 4 million
people then that's a win and by creating
that technology you create new strata
jobs and this is something that people
often don't see is I just see the jobs
have been lost but they don't see the
jobs have been created I mean when it's
a personal computer invented you know
1970 36 right and we employ probably
over 100 computer scientists those jobs
didn't exist when that thing was
invented right and so you also need to
look at there will be displacement but
there'll be new new economy is created
there'll be cottage industries or people
cleaning these vehicles recharging them
right and and even though they're
they're more utilized you're going to be
making more of them there's a lot more
cars made today than horses and
carriages were ever built it will be the
same in these robotic systems they will
increase the size of the market do you
anticipate this essentially obliterating
the traditional car industry well you'll
have a car I think you I think you'll
say personal car ownership dropping and
it's actually been dropping for decades
in any event because people who live in
cities you know the big the big mega
cities I don't want to own a car it's a
pain mean and so we're helping solve
solve that problem you know I think on a
time horizon of you know multiple
decades
yeah people won't be able to drive a car
they'll be considered too dangerous you
know and people won't have those skills
anymore you know just like how many how
many people in this room and this may be
a bit biased because Woodside's not too
far away but how many people in this
room actually know how to ride a horse
okay that's a lot next question but ok
let's go let's get some burning
questions and I'm going to focus on
students first ok great back in the
corner that point I have two questions
turn I mean what when you're in the car
you Jennifer have if you have an
accident or chip somebody coming up to
humans is salt you know west reaction
you'll have to move in human being has
more than two modes when you drive so
all of you is it with like a human being
behind a grill in your car how do you
solve their impact you know
student that can be created so is the
question how do you deal with an
accident how do you prevent an accident
how do you prevent it because when these
two human beings behind well they have
that emotions reactions robot has no
emotion okay so what do you do to
prevent accidents well so the good news
is that 96% of accidents are caused by
human error right and that's good news
well the good news well I mean it's good
news for autonomous technology right and
actually to add on to the previous
question you know we talk about you know
what is the dark side I mean the fact is
you know 40,000 Americans are dying
every year in car accidents more than
million are getting injured and then
globally you have over a million people
dying so when you start with Messier
starting point right there's there's a
lot of ways to improve that technology
the the self-driving vehicles have 360
degrees sensing coverage they're able to
detect not only with cameras to see sort
of visually what things are but they
also have depth sensing right so you
might have radar you might have lighter
these are technologies you can see where
things are in 3d space and so when you
combine this 3d reconstruction that you
can do with the semantic understanding
you get from your cameras you actually
do understand what's going on around you
and you can react to it much much faster
than a human can
so in those situations where somebody
else is doing something strange
somebody's making a weird turn or
they're speeding or persons jumping on
they're not paying attention this type
of technology will be able to react
significantly significantly faster than
a human would and it also won't make
stupid mistakes the same way people do
because you know it's not texting or
drunk though right so although you know
there are very very rare circumstances
where you know some of this sort of
emotional stuff might come into a play I
think we can get rid of probably around
95% of accidents just by being attentive
and not doing stupid things and then for
that last 5% then you start looking at
you know really advanced AI and you know
do you understand people's gestures and
you know emotions and that's a bit
farther out but I think we can make at
least an order of magnitude improvement
before we get to that level of AI great
back there
yes so the system they are building from
the vehicle to the service lapses or a
platform there's a lot of complicated
features if there was one technology
that you most want to see mature is to
just get like ten thousand percent
better with what you pick so the
question is this is a very large
multi-dimensional problem if there was
one technology that you could put the
gas on and and really have a vast
improvement what do you what would be
your dream that's a good one there's a
whole bunch
if someone yeah number one I would say
if somebody could make extremely good
solid-state lidar they can sort of see
out to you know 150 meters in all
directions and be a couple hundred
dollars that'd be pretty great there's a
whole bunch of companies working on it
nobody's figured it out yet
but that would be that'd be pretty cool
for those who general of my Dharma it's
like a it's basically a laser it shoots
out the beam of light and then it
measures how long it takes to bounce
back and then you know the speed of
light so you can figure out how far away
things are right and so what people have
traditionally done today is they've used
a technology called mechanical spinning
lighter and it's these little things
that go like this and they shoot a few
million points per second into the
environment and then measure how long it
take to get back and you get what's
called a 3d point cloud it's a really
good way of knowing where things are in
3d space the technology is still fairly
expensive and it's not automotive grade
yet so there are a whole bunch of people
working on this but it has it hasn't
quite materialized yet so that would be
pretty cool right lidar over there back
there so if the cars go because you know
we have to deal the problem of security
of the car how will you deal with cyber
security threat so how would you deal
with cyber security threat yeah that's a
really good question so I think there's
sort of two to two answers that are sort
of technical and then one that's social
and the social one is that you know
messing with these things is a pretty
pretty bad thing to do and I think there
will be a series of logging there
already are laws but I think they'll be
even more laws that make it extremely
undesirable to mess with this stuff but
from a technical perspective there's
sort of two things you can do the
obvious one is just to have extremely
good encryption right and just have you
know the top two your security team as
well as you can you can shape a
Hathor's to try to break into your
system and then they find all the rules
and you fix them so that's sort of
obvious thing I think the less obvious
thing is the way you actually build the
architecture so that you know the
vehicles will be will be on a network
and be able to do some communication but
you want to make sure that it's actually
physically impossible to command them to
do dangerous things so when we build the
sort of network and communication
infrastructure we're making sure that
even if somebody were to try to instruct
the vehicle to do something really dumb
it would just simply refuse to do that
all the computation is actually
happening locally on the vehicle all
right all the sensing it's all happening
locally right it's not like you're
sending your sensor data over the
network and then it's deciding what to
doing it's sending that back right and
so the vehicle is basically going to
refuse to obey any type of a dangerous
command even if a hacker were to
intercept it so that would be how we
would handle it but it's an it's really
obviously an important topic and it's
one we take very seriously thank you
hello fish Allison ultimate fighting
fraud and cognition so actually I think
your best view of the Australian product
being sounded like in 15 years and
actually a press publications do Adams
Drive it meets time challenge a lot
money and you know resources so it's
quite lucky you have experienced talent
and you are well funded
what do you think about those other you
know small some of them started describe
do listen of trying what's their future
what's their tanks on it's a good chance
to do that so the question is there are
a lot of other small companies that are
popping up trying to tackle the same
problem what do you think about this
ecosystem of other competitors go for it
you know it's it's this is you know
robotics AI mobility safety the
environment zero mission I mean you know
products architecture experience I mean
this is at the intersection of I think
everything that's super compelling you
know these are companies that are on the
vanguard of what's what's possible on
this planet and you know I think the
more people that are looking at the
problem and trying to understand it as
an industry at a whole pushing forward
is the great thing yeah I mean it's
literally now like every two weeks
there's in your self driving car sort of
which is which is fun right I mean
obviously not everybody's going to
to pull something off I think one of the
reasons there's a lot of excitement is
that you know there's there's also a lot
of acquisitions in the space I think
that's partly driving it but you know if
you really if you think it's a bath like
Tim said I mean ground transportation is
a 10 trillion dollar market so you know
for all the money that VCS are putting
into self-driving technology and all the
money that automakers are spending on it
it's a miniscule fraction of 1% of the
overall market so even if some of those
things go and actually pan out I think
overall you look in you know if you look
at the market in 10 years you'll see
that there was a pretty good return on
investment there ok but it has it has
changed I think when Jesse now
incorporated zooks it was just Google
like I think over reached out to Jesse
like a month after one thing I was out
of the business with him because they
weren't they were starting their program
right and and now there's been a
proliferation post that but if you look
at what these startups are doing I mean
they're trying to slap they're trying to
solve a slice of the pie I think what
makes looks unique you know where 240
odd people at the moment you know about
to be over two and half years in is is
that we are trying to do full stack
vertical integration and under product
under one roof we have product
architecture and software and hardware
integration and so I think that makes us
unique not only in the startup community
but also you know like blammo has
decided not to build its own vehicle you
know and and so it's definitely
ambitious you know Zook is not for the
faint of heart and we have a real maker
inventor culture at the company and it's
hard work but you know it's crazy fun at
the same time do you think that some of
the traditional automakers are going to
try to jump into this space very well I
mean they are I mean it's I mean this is
a real Black Swan event you know who
knows who wins I'm as interested as
anyone else see what I'm losing what
happens you know there's various various
historical markers like when we did go
from the automobile from the horse and
carriage the automobile
it wasn't the coachbuilders it figured
it out and they were the titan
industries at the company for their
dave's right it was people like Ford or
Porsche or Benz who understood
mechanical engineering not how to stable
a horse and Bend lever and today the
problem really is a computer science
problem it's its vision and it's AI and
its semantics and understanding in a way
that's robust and and and gives us gives
the vehicle the ability to drive through
the environment with a degree of
competency that the vehicle casually
built for its own time right and and so
if you can
create that and wrap the vehicle around
it then you just might have something
and you know you could argue whether you
know automakers which are about vehicle
dynamics and internal combustion engines
and bending metal at high volume whether
they're well placed to look at the
computer science they are challenges
that actually dig the key to unlocking
this LIF new in this new era of mobility
mobility directly to that point about
training the AI a meeting for the level
of reliability unique so widely rumored
that Zeus is using three reconstructions
of the real world as videogame
simulations for a while they were
divided yeah so there really was perfect
awesome estrangement limits of using
simulation and it's something that we
know says publicly on their website but
they use simulations to training
Superbike Luneberg that way MO and Ford
and others are using simulation so the
question is are you using simulations to
train these people yes we are it's
actually it's actually really exciting
because there's there's two things you
can get out of simulation that you don't
get out of out of real life and by the
way you still need a lot of real-life
data right so we're collecting lots of
real-life data we have a robot team of
150 people just labeling data full-time
using tools we built so we've labeled a
whole bunch of data you know but there's
only so many cars you can see before you
kind of learn what a car is right if
you've labeled ten million examples of
cars and images it's pretty obvious you
know what's the car and what's not a car
right and so one of the reasons why you
know companies like way mo drive so many
miles or you know one of the things that
Tesla is going for to see how these big
fleets they're getting lots of miles
it's not that they want to see you know
seven billion cars instead of two
billion cars its they want to see what
happens in these corners cases right
what happens when something was super
super wrong and they want to get
examples of that the interesting thing
is it's not a very efficient way to get
corner cases right you know I think way
most driven a few million miles so far
and they've seen you know I think they
publicly mentioned a few dozen examples
of really weird stuff that they seem and
but another way to get really weird
sensor data is actually to simulated
right and so one of the things that
we're investing really heavily in is
this idea of sort of building the matrix
for self-driving cars right and when we
talk about simulation we don't just mean
sort of the planning level simulation I
mean we mean down to as you were I guess
it's been widely rumored apparently
right I'm actually recreating you know
sort of 3d models of dynamic models of
cities where you can generate synthetic
lidar data synthetic camera data
synthetic radar data and you actually
run your entire vehicle to a i driving
software in that virtual world and then
you can see how all of the software
interacts because usually when something
goes wrong not just one thing failing
it's usually there is some weird object
and some sensor failed and this other
thing happened it's usually two or three
things you know interacting that caused
the problem and so we can simulate a lot
of those things happening the same time
and then we can see how the vehicle
would react and then we can try to
change your software and make it better
so we believe very heavily in simulation
combined with lots and lots of
real-world data and I think putting
those together you can build something
really safe it's also really important
at market at scale tool you know if you
think about if you have ten thousand
autonomous vehicles in the city and you
want to update the code it's not
practical at that point in the
technologies curve to go and manually
drive you know a million miles or
something like that and even if you did
it might not even reveal something and
so you really need to have a very
advanced simulator that's able to run a
lot of regression testing a lot of
structured tests a lot of virtual tests
to give you the confidence that the
changes you're making its performance to
the system the others are all out back
there oh the two of you funding it with
the red sweater first and then the next
one so for some that you're saying like
the would Zhuge explained accomplish
have iam like a line basically a lot of
a cuticle Thomas system and the very
moment like a full sandwich will almost
kind of a poke anything that has like a
whole cityscape on for which to attach
the vehicle which is a very very large
undertaking for a small company of 200
or so how do you think what you think
would do that advantage to do this
especially a
other types of focusing more specific
things on and yeah how are you so the
question is this is a very complicated
process what makes you what gives you an
advantage in this very complicated
problem well I mean I think I think
we've spoken that too a little bit it is
complex but our our aggressive bet is
that if we keep that complexity on one
under one roof it gives us a competitive
advantage you know if you're like a
mobile eye a tier one like a simple item
an OEM and you're developing a system
then you have to go to an OEM and say
hey we want to talk about how to
integrate it into your car you know and
then have to go through all their
procedures and most manufacture in the
car and produce and put it in the
marketplace the these large company that
is very slow slow progress
whereas if you sell very strong
recursive frameworks in one entity you
know the ability to field of vehicle get
all the diagnostics and data off that
vehicle train on and put it back in the
vehicle and that is happening in one
entity that becomes very powerful in our
view and so that that that's what we're
really trying to do is serve these
recursive frameworks you know simulation
is actually recursive framework a
fractal framework that gives us out the
community to tell us the types of
engineers you have work in there because
and that'll give us sort of a sense of
the range of types of problems you're
trying to solve yeah it's actually
really fun I mean one of the things that
makes me super excited to go to work
every day is that there's such a diverse
group of people even within engineering
but obviously broader than engineering
but you know it's an engineering I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
computer scientists but even then though
you have people from the gaming industry
get people from motion planning from
computer vision you know other types of
machine learning you have people you
know we have a mazing infrastructure
team right we realized about a year ago
like craft we we sort of need you know
almost Google level infrastructure if we
want to you know do this stuff seriously
now we're not literally building Google
level infrastructure but we're also
building a lot more infrastructure than
you typically see at a start-up right so
we're building a computing cluster with
you know many many hundreds of Nvidia
you know Pascal Titan X GPUs right stuff
like that and so we have a whole
infrastructure team people used to
building that kind of stuff you know we
have mechanical engineers we have you
know optical engineers all kinds of you
know different types of electrical
engineers pretty much you know we're
doing enough stuff that you know if
there's a type of engineering is a
there's a good chance we have one
or a few straight super is you talking
about Daenerys could you talk about
silent love it shake you who you are
today whether it is professional EO
temperamentally great I learnt that
questions get a defining moment in your
career that shaped who you are today
oh gosh hmm well yeah I want to just
think HM this is interesting right think
you can grow very very very different
background as probably it's probably
when it's my grade two at school well
what happened I was kept down here
because I spelt cat with a cake haha
that's what you've all be kids in your
name yeah that's part of it actually but
but yeah it was you know so my take-home
message to there with all Tim's just
dumb right but maybe I am maybe I'm not
we'll find out but but that was that
sort of that sort of really got me
thinking about how things work on deeper
levels why did that happen and did you
feel like you had to prove something or
just was did you come away thinking you
were a creative thinker
yeah definitely I think you know through
my through my yongi is that you
definitely you know have something to
show and some to prove what happened
right did you go back and talk to your
second-grade teacher
I don't think she particularly wanted to
talk not a most well disciplined child
aha okay well we know a lot of those in
this room too so much Jesse a defining
moment hmm that's a tough one I think
one one that stands out for me was the
night before the 2007 DARPA urban
challenge you know there was we were
very small teen at Stanford I think
there were only four of us actually
wrote the code for for our vehicle and
DARPA had told us that you know they
were they weren't going to give us the
digital map file until the morning of
the race but then they decided the night
before they'd give everybody the map
file just to make sure there's no
surprises right but we had frozen our
code several days before and we weren't
touching anything and they give us the
map file and it turned out that they had
about twenty times more of these sort of
digital waypoints then then we thought
it would have because every file did
giving us previously if there was a
straight road they'd just be one way
point at the beginning and one at the
end and that was it
and all of a sudden this file had every
meter there was a waypoint and so we
tried to load it and it was just too
slow and the entire thing didn't work it
was like you know 11:00 p.m. and the Ray
the next morning and we're like well
this is this is not good right so it was
actually just a really fun three hours
because we had to come up with a whole
new set of elegantly fine it was super
fun we we had to come up with a whole
new algorithm to like parse that file
and search the search the the road
network and then sort of test it and
then sort of hope it would work in next
morning and it's actually fun because we
had sort of all these sort of technical
arguments like well should we do this
way or that way and I sort of made my
case and Sebastian my advisors that said
okay I think I think yours makes sense
let's go try it so I coat it up and it's
sort of you know seemed like it worked
and then we ran it the next day and it
actually worked and then you know we got
to watch our robot car drive you know
for six hours and not screw up at all
and come back to the end and to me that
was really exciting because I think
before that before that race it was like
you know is any of this stuff even going
to workers it's just too hard and then
you know you see it do those six hours
and you need to come back and you're
like that was the first time where I
felt like you know obviously there's
tons of work to do because the first
time where I felt like hey this is
really possible and it's coming you know
at some point in the future that's great
well so let's let's then talk about the
business for for a few minutes
you guys are co-founders you come from
really different backgrounds different
areas of expertise how do you work
together as co-founders especially if
you have different points of view about
something how does that work out one one
funny thing I learned from Jessie is he
has this really cool way of
communicating in that you know we're
discussing something you go yeah I don't
feel strongly about that I'm like cool
well some people say I feel quite
strongly about Ella talk and so on
sometimes I feel very strongly this is
not the right thing to do and so it's
kind of nice that there's this sort of
scale right and and when we both feel
very and it's not often that we actually
feel very strongly that this is the
wrong thing to do with each other you
know so the first thing I don't think
you need is mutual respect so you can
listen to the person and then I think
when you do get to that situation where
you both feel very strongly about
something you know you really need to go
back to first principles and decompose a
problem and why it is and unfortunately
for me you know Jessie's one of the most
rational people I've ever met and so
that's that's a good way to process it
and sometimes sometimes the answer is
you know we'll well let's just go and
explore that thing and see what happens
and if we're wrong it's not the end of
the world you know or or let's go and
get some data to see how that that works
so Jessie that is a very mature thing
that idea of sort of making it clear
what things are important and not
important where did you learn that so
that's a good question
I don't know I think I've had a pretty
good role models both of my parents my
mom if you're high you know we're pretty
good at you know encouraging me to be
inquisitive you know I think that's part
of it comes from be inquisitive and also
part of it comes from just trying to be
reasonable right and not saying okay I
have to get my way all the time
right and and you know I think you know
sort of my answer the question and I
like your answer but I'll you know I
think for me as well it's it's about
actually genuinely respecting each other
right and it doesn't respect does it
mean that you know you always defer to
the other person or you soom they're
always right it doesn't mean that at all
and it doesn't mean that you're both
equally skilled in all areas but it
means that I think you know in our case
if we do disagree we assume I think a
couple things that are important so
first of all that we're both being
genuine right I never questioned Tim's
intentions or why you think something is
even being fleeting right sometimes I'm
like hey I don't agree with you on that
but I don't have to worry if there's you
know some ulterior motive or any of that
kind of crap cause I think if you have
to deal with that level of uncertainty
or distrust I don't think you can make
something like this work and then the
other is you know Tim's a super smart
guy and I only took me about an hour of
meeting him to realize that even though
he didn't come from through the
traditional engineering background like
he doesn't really matter at the end of
the day right a lot of what we're doing
is about coming up with new
architectures and coming up with you
know creative solutions to technical
problems and if you can reason from
first principles which Tim is extremely
good at it you know it doesn't
necessarily matter if you know if he
can't you know code up something in C++
it's a little bit beside the point so I
think you know one of the reasons why
we're able to work together even in very
technical areas we can have you know fun
three-hour conversation back and forth
and and I think you know Tim is
sometimes frustratingly good at you know
II think up and you know he doesn't he
doesn't sort of take you know anybody's
and anybody save and just you know
verbatim he's always thinking for
himself which again every once in a
while that's frustrating but it's
actually an amazingly good quality in a
CEO I mean one thing I'd add to that is
it's okay for there to be conflict it's
how you process it right like what six
is doing has never been done before it's
basically a group of people who don't
know what they're doing
to quaintly right and and so for me when
I see people locked in argument I
actually enjoy it because I'm like I
love the passion and you need that
passion if people aren't arguing
fiercely about how to do something has
never been done before I mean they know
that you've got the wrong people and so
on a high level it's actually quite a
quid signal but you do want to balance
and keep it keep it healthy we call that
creative friction yeah I call it being
comfortable has been uncomfortable right
so I have a thousand more questions but
I'm going to just ask one more because
we just are going to run out of time and
I would love to know what really
motivates each of you this is a really
big hard problem something with a very
long deadline you know long sort of
vision into the future what is it that
drive to you in this very big endeavor
sure yeah I mean I think for me it's
seeing people being able to use
something that they don't necessarily
understand but they find to be amazing
and they find to make their life better
in some meaningful way you know I I love
solving you know technological problems
coming up with creative solutions to
them not for the sake of you know just
writing a paper you know I've done that
it's fun like I like going to
conferences but at the end of the day
like when you can actually create
something that somebody can use and they
don't understand how it works but they
they can tell that it's amazing that's
super rewarding for me and that's
actually why I wanted to work with Tim
on zukes
because I knew that you know at the end
of the day there will be other companies
that figure out autonomous technology
right we're not going to be the only one
that's ever figured this stuff out right
and at the end of the day the customers
getting in these vehicles are going to
care a lot about the product in the
experience and what is it like and how
do they work and of course it has to
work and be safe and I love all these
into technology element of that but you
know getting in as yukl and thinking
that it's kind of magical like I think
that's really important and you know Tim
brings all of that and a lot more the
table and that'sa me seem like something
worth working on we also have to make
the paperwork I'm trying and so yeah I
mean for me it's that it's it's you're
connecting people in places but for me
it's also it's also you know I have a
background in
Meishan and what we're really doing here
is is animating matter and we're
animating in a way that it becomes
independent from us you know Silicon
Valley was founded on computation
Silicon Valley right in a way that
computation now is been plugged into
sensors and algorithms that can make
sense semantically of what's happening
around it and that's going down to
electrical through electromechanical
actuation and that feedback loop can
drive drive a device through the
environment that's robotics and so I
find that fascinating as an animator and
a creative creative person is to figure
out spatially and geometrically how to
solve that product and and ultimately I
think that's important for cities today
but it's also important you know for
expanding possible of what's possible on
this planet you know and so I could say
you know we're going to create
autonomous mobility and then explore the
universe because ultimately I think
that's where intelligent robots go Wow
thank you so much for animating us
[Music]
[Applause]
you